j'ai enfin ce dont j'ai toujours rêvé
carthage est dit on devrait être d'or en
train de croquer des méchants
je suis un prédateur le besoin d'être
libre doit apprendre à contrôler ton
agressivité
où l'on mettra en cash dans la zone 51
tu vis dans mon corps tu dois obéir à
des règles non
qu'est ce qui m'a pris laisse moi te
ranger sort mieux de leurs castle est un
loser
eddie brock je veux vous confier mon
histoire
les gens aiment les tueurs en série ou
foetus pourquoi moi ce qui est mien est
vôtre et ce qui est votre et bien
j'ai déjà monté au sang humain et ça
c'est autre chose
pied enfin ce dont j'ai toujours rêvé
un carnage
je suis par un psychopathe
je suis vraiment en colère
oh
ou tu vas le rouge
dépêche-toi de sortie je te laisserais
manger tout le monde promet pas ma
parole joe plus
m
je te connais par coeur
comme mon frère
[Musique]
hu qui pourrait déjà se comptent pas
pour toi ça aurait dû être nous je suis
content pour toi
non pardon vous suis désolé pour moi ils
ont besoin d'une bonne thérapie de coûts